space matters to all of us in Europe not
only to science-fiction fans or
modern-day discoverers
what happens up there has a big impact
on our lives down here daily life
depends on the technologies services and
data that space helps to deliver when we
use our mobile phone drive our car take
the plane watch satellite TV or even
when we withdraw cash from the bank
space data helps to save lives at sea it
improves our response to earthquakes
forest fires and floods it allows our
farmers to plan ahead it helps us to
protect the environment and fight
climate change
Europe's space industry has seized these
opportunities it is strong and
competitive and it creates jobs by
working together sharing resources and
investing in a common future we are
pushing the boundaries of what is
possible today we want to ensure that
European citizens get the best value for
every euro we spend Copernicus is
already one of the world's leading
providers of Earth observation data now
we are taking it to the next level so
that it strengthens our security systems
and helps to monitor greenhouse gas
emissions
Galileo our own global satellite
navigation system will soon provide more
accurate and reliable positioning and
timing information our planes trains and
cars will be more efficient and we want
to help all the new startups who see
space as their next frontier by making
it easier for them to access and use
space data all of this is vital to
Europe security and defence and close
cooperation with our global partners
will only make us safer Europeans have
always looked to the Stars for
inspiration today our cooperation in
space improves the lives of millions of
people here on
you